so this is it it's all Italy
ready let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody happy trailer Bowl Sunday
how about the way they opened that shop
with them all on the Milano like just
showing you yeah they're definitely
going to outer space and I love Tom
Hollands look when he has the hood off
of his new iron spider costume Tony
Stark's model primer actually looks like
it comes out of his glasses because he
like holds his hands up to them and they
just disappear into the gauntlets so
maybe like during Civil War when he had
the wristwatch that turned into a device
he has this entire suit that comes out
of the glasses in the arc reactor in his
chest because that's the only thing
that's there all the time probably gonna
be a lot of questions about that Iron
Man 3 ending for a long time but I felt
like they kind of addressed that during
the Avengers films like yeah you knew he
was gonna come back and be Iron Man
again I think they just wanted to do
that in case he didn't resign their
contract so they're like okay we need to
have him ride off into the sunset if he
never comes back but of course that
never happened so we get a better look
at some of these big action set-pieces
what they did is is they've expanded on
the previous trailer they drop so I'll
link that one at the end of this so you
can compare but I also just posted that
Thanos teaser with the longer scene so
couples infinity war videos dropping
really recently but I love the way that
they expand on this vision Scarlet Witch
scene where she's sort of messing with
her powers in the mind gem at the same
time you can see it exchanging energy
they're having some weird psychic space
sex communion with the Infinity gem
there's just so many things that we
don't know about the gems in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that right now if you
were to ask what they're capable of
you could just say anything and you
would not be wrong which is kind of a
problem but for the most part the reason
they do stuff like that is so they don't
paint themselves into a story corner
later on so that when they had Thanos
assemble all the gems in the gauntlet by
the fourth Avengers film they could just
have him do whatever they wanted to and
it wasn't like something that was
predetermined six movies ago only the
fact that he would assemble the gauntlet
but this shot of the Guardians walking
out of the Milano looks like them
landing on earth I'm guessing that's
where they meet because obviously Peter
and iron man have to get up there
somehow and if they're walking out it's
on ground but the big thing here is that
Peter quill has not been back to earth
since he left with yondu when he was a
boy like he was just too painful for him
so that's why James Gunn
did that weird time jump with guardians
one and two so that he could have that
moment with his father ego the Living
Planet and sort of get a resolution to
that find out what really happened to
his mother then make peace with that
over a period of time so I'll try to
explain what the timeline is between
guardians to an infinity war when we get
to the movie in a couple months but like
I said biggest reason why he hadn't been
to earth before that is just because he
hadn't dealt with the death of his
mother and that's what his experience
with his father was all about for those
of you asking about his power to because
he's part celestial so his DNA is still
part celestial so if ego ever came back
he would probably get that godlike power
back but now he's back to being about as
powerful as you always thought that he
was might be a little more resilient
because of his physiology but he doesn't
have crazy weird energy powers anymore
love the reunion between Iron Man and
Hulk like he's so happy to see him
but obviously [ __ ] is going down so he's
like well this is bad as good as we're
gonna be able to do all right let's do
it
everybody armor up Thor in the sanctum
if you couldn't tell we got a much
better look at that during Thor Ragnarok
oh yeah this is obviously much more
serious but I do think that they'll play
it for a couple of funny moments like
how could it not be funny that hope
crashes through the sanctum like hey
buddy where are you where you been this
whole time and he has to fill him in on
all the events of Ragnarok love the shot
of rocket and Thor in the trawler this
looks like they're on their way to that
special space Forge where Thor makes his
new weapon still no official
confirmation about what it is we've all
seen the toys I've done a couple videos
about it it's probably gonna wind up
being the ax but I wouldn't be surprised
if they held back on some of that stuff
till the later trailers or the actual
movie itself some stuff they'll never
show you in the trailers we get a better
shot of what looks like Loki on the same
planet surface where Iron Man gets the
beatdown or the person wearing the Iron
Man armor gets the beatdown from Thanos
at the end of the trailer that we saw
last time this is actually really badass
because what suit is spider-man wearing
he's wearing the old version of the
costume when he jumps on that big
cylinder so think about it this way he's
on the bus his spidey sense goes
off the charts he sees that big cylinder
above Manhattan so he makes a dash for
it jumps up on it tries to start taking
it down and this is probably where
Ironman activates his iron spider armor
and it probably just goes on to him like
we saw during Iron Man 3 like he just
has the different pieces that attach to
him so that's probably how he gets it he
doesn't climb into it one leg at a time
it just assembles around him like the
earlier versions of Iron Man's armor
Iron Man still gets the coolest version
of the armor so obviously it's way more
advanced than the Spider Man armor I'm
the best
this is Captain America finally
returning to the New Avengers facility
it looks like it's right before or right
after they say vision from the Black
Order but it's just a really heavy
moment because he hasn't come back and
remember he's still the Nomad character
he still has a really tune down colour
version of the costume he doesn't have
that black panther shield that we see
later in the trailer which is badass we
see how the gauntlets work it basically
forms out of one of his arms when Thor
says ready he's probably talking to
rocket it probably just corresponds to
that scene where he's standing on this
big forge in the middle of outer space a
little bit of teenage Groot he doesn't
look a whole lot bigger than we saw him
at the end of guardians 2 so I'm
guessing there was a big time jump
during that Guardians post-credits scene
and he's supposed to be like 13 14 years
old this shot of nebula looks like it
also corresponds to that earlier shot
that we saw fan OHS giving the beatdown
to them with the gauntlet and it might
be the ruins of the Nova Corps because a
lot of these don't look like earth based
structures so they knows might just wipe
that out on his way to get the power gem
and he uses the gem to just blow
everything up bigger shard of the
outriders invasion black widow with
adora milosh a obviously a lot of these
people are fighting each other during
the black panther trailer so once you go
see that movie you'll understand what's
going on there but I wouldn't really
consider that much of a spoiler
what Khanda forever is an important idea
for the Black Panther movie so even
though there's a lot of Civil War
happening during that they get their
[ __ ] together before the outriders
invade new shot a Winter Soldier with
the vibranium arm that Shuri makes for
him is that I love this Doctor Strange
Sherlock team-up moment
where he cast an enchantment and Ironman
flies right through with his armor on
his way to punch probably one of the
black order is probably gonna be evany
maw coming to grab the time gem I'll be
interested to see if dr. strange uses it
during this fight too like something
terrible happens he wins time back like
he did during the Doctor Strange movie
so that's about it with the exception of
that final shot at Thanos just looking
determined I love this smiley cracks on
his face like he's not openly smiling
but he looks really excited for what's
to come in time you will know what it is
to lose but let me know in the comments
what do you guys think of the footage
and there is a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber
share the video using the tools on the
watch page congratulations to the winner
from my last Avengers video stoner 9th
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll just announce
a new winner when I post new marble just
a reminder that there's actually gonna
be a venom trailer in a Deadpool 2
trailer dropping before Black Panther
drops in theaters so there's a bunch of
new comic-book stuff coming in the next
two weeks but click here to watch that
Thanos scene and click here for the
first infinity war trailer again thank
you so much for watching everybody and
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight